[Music]
this story is about the longest biggest
and probably most lucrative bankruptcy
in history
lehman brothers staff arrived at work in
london this morning to be told the bank
had been put into administration
it's got 600 billion uh dollars in
assets nothing like that had ever gone
bust before
nothing really like that has ever gone
but since it's not good
it sucks
everyone remembers the boxes being
carried out by bankers
um but the story didn't end there for
some people it's continued to be their
life's work where'd you want me to kind
of look i kind of was embarrassed to say
i worked at lehman whereas now i feel
proud
this company which is sort of
you know the biggest corporate failure
in history
it turns out that there actually is
quite a lot of money in there
if you bought early
it's pretty hard not to have made money
on lehman you could be looking at maybe
40 times back your money having seen the
value of these things go from
as close to zero as anyone can be
bothered to make a trade happen at
all the way up to the the highest trade
at 50 percent
has been of course life-changing
it's probably one of the biggest
distressed debt trades in hedge fund
history
[Music]
lehman brothers staff arrived at work in
london this morning to be told the bank
had been put into administration it's
disastrous but i think people are
experienced enough and professional
enough to take it on the chin
when the news came on that monday it was
shock there were just people standing
around in huddles and groups
because we didn't know what was going to
happen
you know text messages were flying
around to say that the office was going
to be locked that we wouldn't be able to
get in
that our personal belongings would all
be carted off into some skip and dump to
the you know the side of the road
brought down by bad mortgage investments
lehman which has 25 000 employees will
be liquidated
when i started working on lehman one of
the things i found out is that there
were people working at lehman in the uk
and in the us as well who had been
working at lehman's before it went bust
and they were still there
so most people lehman's has been long
dead but to these people
lehman's is still very much the core
part of their lives
i started at lehman april 1989 so that's
nearly 33 years ago
um i think the time we went into
insolvency there was probably about
6 000 odd people in europe 5 000 plus of
those were in in the london headquarters
lehman brothers
goes bust very quickly which is kind of
unusual lima was about as close to like
a free-fall bankruptcy as experts would
call it
than any other bankruptcy with panic
spreading wall street looked for who
would be the next to fall
number one on the list was lehman
brothers with massive exposure to the
crumbling mortgage market after years of
buying in big
you know the broad story about lehman is
that basically they got stuck with a
load of subprime uh subprime uh mortgage
bonds um which are mortgage bonds of a
lower credit quality i.e the borrower is
less likely to pay back than other
mortgage bonds and they can't shift them
and that makes people wonder about the
quality
of
their book of loans their their their
assets
and because of that
the assets um that lehman has
are being sold for basically nothing
its stock price tanking lehman with the
government's help tried to find a buyer
but no luck after a summer of rescues
the political appetite for another huge
wall street bailout was gone and the 150
year old firm was finished
lehman's london office had to be closed
immediately
i had a
an email from um one of my contacts at
pricewaterhousecoolcooperspwc
and they said you know don't freak out
but there's some guys from insolvency
team going to be coming to the office
and
and then once i got that email i thought
oh my god this is serious
in the uk
pwc come in as the administrator
administrators basically a term for the
accountants in this case they're
officers of the court who are there to
look after and wind down the business in
this morning's top corporate news
creditors of lehman brothers filed more
than 16 000 claims before yesterday's
deadline wilmington trust which is a
trustee for various lehman senior notes
says it may be owed as much as 73
billion
so in the u.s in the uk
you have these assets and you think
they're going to be worth something at
some point but while everyone's
panicking they're not going to be worth
anything who wants to own a lehman bond
you know you've just watched the news
where everyone's coming out with their
boxes it doesn't look like a great
credit so
nobody really wants to buy it and then
you've got the other problem that nobody
has any money anyway there's an absence
of liquidity in the financial system the
oldest money market fund in the nation
wrote off roughly three quarters of a
billion dollars in bad debt issued by
the now bankrupt lehman brothers
[Music]
so my name is daryl ratigan i started
lehman in 2004 as a secondi and i have
continued to work for lehman
administration
to manage the commercial property and
related exposures that haven't even had
lehman brothers now go to court where a
judge will take control of the bank
until its assets are sold
the lehman insolvency has
various different strands in the uk we
have an administration process
and the largest company in the uk was a
company called lehman brothers
international europe often referred to
as libby
everyone likes to tidy up after
themselves uh you know
when the lehman thing fell off the cliff
there was a lot of mess on the floor to
clean up
so you know if a company is insolvent
the chances are that you're not going to
get all your money back so you'll be
getting something less than 100 p in the
pound
to the extent but you know there has
been something to sell
you might get 20 30 40 50 p in the pound
the libby creditors have actually got
something of 100 around about 140 p in
the pound
so when a company
goes bust it has to pay its creditors
and it has to do in a particular order
and that queue
we call a waterfall
basically what happens is the cash comes
out of the company and then it has to go
to someone first and then i'll go to a
second person and then i'll go to a
third person so imagine a waterfall
coming down and you've got these little
buckets
and the top bucket might be called super
senior secured and then there might be a
bucket in the middle called unsecured
and then there'll be another bucket
called subordinated and there'll be
another bucket called equity and people
get paid in that order so once the first
bucket is full up
then the next bucket gets filled up then
the next bucket gets filled up
and those buckets have been filled up a
lot
if you're looking at the european
uk listed uk issued debt
you
will get paid 100 of the face value bear
in mind these are being sold for nothing
close to that value um when the company
was going bust and then you get a load
of interest on top and in the uk some of
the people who held on and waited for
that bucket to fill up i've had to wait
a long time but they've got their
buckets overflowing
[Music]
hi i'm robert suthee i'm the founder of
southie capital
and we are a firm that are focused on
trading bankruptcy claims and distressed
debt so uh the libby debts
uh they finally settled at about 144
percent of power
so the holders of that who held all the
way through um received you know
substantial recovery
plus uh statutory interest
um
and the the whole estate
probably paid out around 17 billion uh
sterling
[Music]
the vast majority of the recovery is
coming from assets which were marked at
a very low value in 2008
and subsequently recovered huge amounts
and
had enough time been given to the
company perhaps it would have traded out
of its
problems and survived
much more money has been realized from
lehman to state than would have been
thought possible
it's pretty unusual
that unsecured creditors will get paid
this much money
pretty unusual that they get paid back
in full
very unusual that they get interest and
in between that you actually have the
tax man
so a billion pounds of tax was paid
to hmrc which you know probably isn't in
the press very much but you know that's
a bit that's a big number for the
exchequer to receive
so now i kind of feel proud and when
people say who'd you work for and i say
lehman they
lehman is that still going we thought
that went ages ago and you say well
actually no there were six and a half
thousand people in europe and now
there's
four or five of us left and they just
cannot believe it
[Music]
i'm not sure i want to be the last
person to turn lights off but i'm kind
of quite
keen to be
around to close those last romanian
entities
that's it blank piece of paper again and
i can move on
[Music]
you